foreign
all right so without further delay let's
start with today's webinar so hello
everyone a very warm greeting to one and
all my name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
the first session on buying marriage for
infectious disease program
this program is dedicated to the study
of viral diversity and its role in
epidemic intellectual diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic spillover
transmission between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
ever
and in the first session we will gain an
overview of Next Generation sequencing
wherein we will cover topics on read
sequences file formats alignment
annotation and non-matteries and
Alignment to databases of biologies
so before we begin with today's session
for those of you who are joining with us
for the very first time let me take a
brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a USB
blind Medics company who is working with
multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
and as a part of our mission our team is
working with local and Regional
coordinators that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training have been completed by over 24
000 participants from 187 countries in
over 300 workshops influx different
specialization tracks that includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine neuroscience and data science
for biomedical data and as a part of the
training you will have access to the
owning storage resources which takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the students a clear path to the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid
and this also comes with an access to
the omic sorted courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-onic that includes
genomic transcriptomic metagenomic and
epigenomic data science that makes use
of bioinformatics using R and python as
well as Chemin format and example
projects of the Philippines which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research
and the women's logic platform also
gives options for analyzing a given data
set with data set and Associated
Publications can be used in several ways
that is you can learn bioinformatics
without any coding at all for those
interested in opting the non-code
pathway they will be given directions to
access the T bind to platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
biomatic pipeline and different stages
of analysis are performed in different
sections on this multi-atomics platform
and for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omexologic code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
so now to view the various courses
example projects you need to first sign
up on the women's logic learn portal
before that let me walk you through a
brief demo on what a completed profile
on the portal look like so once you sign
up on the portal these are the features
that you need to update on account that
a completed profile will have a profile
image a full name with the appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handle a brief bio about yourself that
will consist of your education
background and research interest the
mentors can do your progress under the
activity tab the courses you are
currently completed will appear under
the core system finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates
so with that let us Begin by signing up
on the home of storage plan portal
so those of you who have not signed up
yet
kindly sign up and pasting the link for
signing up in the chat book
so please visit the link and I'll show
you how you can sign up on the portal so
for those of you who have not signed up
please click on the create an account
option that you see here
once you click on this you will be able
to enter your name email ID and password
and you can sign up or you can also sign
up using any of your social media levels
this could be Google Facebook account
Apple account GitHub account or even
Twitter
and for those of you who have already
signed up you can simply click on the
login now option and enter your existing
email ID and password and sign so with
that I'll pause for a couple of seconds
for the participants to sign up and sign
in and once you have please put a yes in
the chat post so that I can proceed
ahead
[Music]
foreign
ER thank you so much
what about the rest of you have you also
sign up
thank you so much
thank you Harvey thank you Karthik all
right so
um since the participants are signing up
I'm just going to proceed ahead along
the way we are facing any technical
challenges please let us know in the
chat and we'll be happy to guide you so
since I already have an account on the
portal I'm going to directly click on
sign in
so once you sign in you will be visiting
the courses picture so here you will be
able to see the various courses and
example projects that are there on the
portal and once you scroll below you'll
be able to see a search bar that says
looking for a specific course so here if
you enter a keyword or research interest
then you that that will show you the
various courses and example projects
that makes use of work for example since
a lot of the participants are interested
in infectious diseases if you enter the
keyword infectious disease it will show
you the various courses and example
projects that range from tuberculosis
infection malaria infection fast food
too and so on so the Valentine can take
a look at all of these at their own pace
I just wanted to show you how you can
navigate the course attack
and coming to the part where you have to
set up your profile for that you can
click on this blue bar that is welcome
back with your email ID
when you click on this it'll directly
take you to your account setting here
when you will see an icon that says
profile that will enable you to edit all
the features that I was talking about in
my presentation that is and that it
better you should have a full name it's
appropriate capitalization you should
add a bio that consists of your
education background and research
interest add a profile image for
yourself as link your social media
so that was about setting up the profile
and then you'll also see several tabs
under your profile under the activity
tab like I mentioned the program enter
and the community manager they will be
tracking your learning progress the
courses that you're currently taking
will show up under the courses tab
once you complete a research project on
the program on the portal that will be
displayed under the projects tab and
once you enroll for the program the
program progress can be viewed under the
program tab finally after the completion
of your coursework the PS2 server the
required quizzes and assignments the
certificates will prepare the v38
so another important tab that I want to
show you is the project staff which will
show the various student projects that
have been completed as a part of
development programs and the topics
range from infectious disease Precision
medicine Neuroscience machine learning
data science and so on so the
participants can have a look at all of
these student projects as well at their
own pace so that was all about
navigating through the portal and with
that now I'd like to pass on the stage
to sonalica we'll be starting with the
session so over to yourself
thank you so much SRI Gary
can you please confirm if my screen is
visible
yes we can see your slide
all right thank you so much good evening
everyone a good morning and good
afternoon in whichever part of the world
you are today we will discuss and to
proceed ahead with the first session of
the program bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
we have designed this program to
introduce the data resources the tools
that you can use to apply bioinformatics
to publicly available data on infectious
diseases in this program you will
understand the viral diversity and its
role in epidemic infectious diseases
that keep re-emerging including zoonotic
transmission transmission between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development we learn about
bioinformatics analysis approaches to
study viral genomes and understand the
relationships between viral strains
haplotypes finding differences in
sequence data and seeing the
implications for drug and vaccine design
you'll gain the hands-on experience by
analyzing curated data sets from
publicly available domain collections
Guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about virology
we'll also address some questions about
infectious diseases like what is a
pathogen where do diseases come from
what causes their diseases how do these
diseases spread how to treat and or
prevent the diseases and what remains to
be done
Global survey shows that in 2019
antimicrobial resistance killed more
people than HIV or Aids or Malaria
deaths from drug resistant tuberculosis
account for about one third of all
antimicrobial resistance deaths
worldwide
before we get started let us discuss
what an infection is and what are these
different types of infectious diseases
so an infection is the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by disease
causing agents their multiplication and
the reaction of host tissues to the
Infectious agents and the toxins they
produce an infectious disease also known
as transmissible disease or communicable
disease is an illness resulting from an
infection infections are caused by
infectious agents called pathogens which
includes viruses and related agents such
as viroids bacteria fungi parasites
unicellular organisms that is malaria
Toxoplasma babiesia or macro parasites
like worms or helmets including
nematodes such as parasitic round worms
and pinworms tapeworms and flutes as
well non-infectious diseases are also
recognized as chronic and can be caused
by such factors as environment nutrition
and lifestyle as well as inheritance W
by Joe recognizes only four main types
of chronic and non-infectious diseases
which are cancer cardiovascular chronic
respiratory diseases like asthma or
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
and diabetes
infectious diseases are caused by
pathogenic microorganisms such as
bacteria viruses and parasites there are
many different types of infectious
diseases some of which are common than
others like respiratory infections
including common cold influenza
pneumonia tuberculosis gastrointestinal
infections including gastroenteritis
cholera and hepatitis a sexually
transmitted infections that are spread
through sexual contact including
chlamydia gonorrhea syphilis HIV and
AIDS vector-borne infections that are
transmitted by vectors such as
mosquitoes stakes and flows zoonotic
infections that are transmitted from
animals to humans such as rabies Ebola
and bird flu or skin infections which
includes impetigo cellulitis and
ringworm are blood-borne infections that
are spread through blood such as
Hepatitis B and C and HIV or Aids and
then we have fungal infections and
parasitic infections as well that are
caused by fungi and parasites
respectively which could include
ringworm candidiitis malaria
trichomoniasis or taxoplasmosis it's
important to know that some infectious
diseases can fall into multiple
categories and some disease can be
caused by more than one type of
microorganism as well
the replication of pathogens in the host
leads to Major interference starting
from membrane disruption as in the case
with viruses and the release of toxins
as in the case of many bacterial
pathogens many of these interferences
induce molecular biological Pathways
designed to fend off Intruders and
signal to enabling cells of danger the
pathogens can also modulate these
Pathways and cause long-term organ
damage such as lung tissue scarring due
to the immune hyperactivity
now to treat these pathogens vaccines
were designed first as far back as the
early 1800s and were becoming major
instruments to train the human immune
system in response to various pathogens
reducing worldwide deaths significantly
in the 20th century as a result of water
treatment use of vaccines and
antibiotics death rate from infectious
diseases was reduced 10 folds in the
20th century but in the 21st century
came around with the new challenges
antibiotic resistant bacteria a new
challenge from novel pandemic viruses
that were not that we were not prepared
for
thankfully at the same time that the
pathogens were studied under the
microscopes humans also started
developing sequencing technologies that
could help deciful the human genome as a
result such detailed and Rich molecular
data has transformed our understanding
of infectious diseases
in the last 20 years availability of
genomic data has led to an increasing
understanding of how cells function at
the molecule at the molecular level and
has allowed us to understand major
causes of deadly diseases
with the current rise in viral outbreaks
and their deadlines there is a major
focus on developing tools and data
repositories for a better
the standing of the emergence prevention
and treatment of infectious diseases as
a result there are major advances in
data generation analysis methods and
utilization of insights from such
studies is making a completely new
approach to Diagnostics disease
characterization and development of
interventions
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed immensely to our
understanding of infectious diseases
from disease pathogenesis mechanisms of
interaction the spread of antimicrobial
resistance to host immune responses as a
result the emergence of genomic medicine
has substantially Advanced our ability
to detect study and treat infectious
diseases
these achievements came as a result of a
close collaboration between computer
scientists and biologists placing
bioinformatics at the center of current
advances in this domain
as a result omics data is now regularly
used to study viral genomes DNA
variation host gene expression protein
abundance and composition properties of
microbial communities all very different
types of data that we need to
effectively study and mine for patterns
to understand host pathogen interaction
the role of bioinformatics in general
and in the context of infectious
diseases is to allow researchers to
access process analyze and visualize
these kinds of high throughput data and
today I will introduce several examples
of how this was done successfully by
researchers studying violence infections
like the Ebola virus outbreak in West
Africa covid-19 pandemic as well as
microbial pathogens causing tuberculosis
and single cell parasites that cause
malaria we will briefly touch on viral
genomics and evolution gene expression
patterns and detection of significant
genomic variants as well as the
important aspects of microbiome and
biome communities in a host that are
being studied to find important
association with disease susceptibility
and outcomes
the Y room is one part of the microbiome
which constitutes all of the organisms
that inhabit us including bacterial and
archaeal organisms as well as the
microbiome and other members of of
myophona such as protests and meta zones
studies of the virum are in their
infancy because it has only recently
become possible to see the wide room in
large sequence data sets using
bioinformatics tools that can detect
relationships between viruses despite
extreme nucleotide sequence diversity
the size of the mammalian by ROM is not
known Although our own cells are
outnumbered about 10-fold by our
bacterial microbiome the number of
viruses may be 10 fold higher still
human feces alone contains 100 to 108 to
109 viruses per gram and each and either
mammalian Byron is continuously updated
through Rapid evolution of viruses and
through exposure to viruses in the
environment or in other mammals
now here is the scale of sequencing
information that is available in genbank
uh the first graph here shows the
percentage growth of sequences deposited
on genbank between August 2009 and
August 2010 sequences are grouped based
on the genbank classification of
division either by their High taxonomy
or the sequencing method employed and
the graph on the right side shows the 20
most frequently sequenced viruses
appearing on genbank sequences were
identified here based on their organism
name as described in each submission
thankfully the specific outbreak brought
about a huge collection of data this
information is becoming widely
accessible millions of sequences and
hundreds of thousands of function arms
are available on repositories hosted by
the national Center of biotechnology
information and other databases like the
joint genome institutions integrated
microbial genomes database these
databases are growing in size at an
exponential speed
many different sequencing techniques
were introduced over the years
sequencing platforms use a variety of
Redlands the benefit of short reads
isn't that they're short but that they
can be very inexpensive and can be
generated in a massively parallel manner
with billions of uh with billions being
generated in a single run where Cost
needs to be kept down and the read
counts must be high the short free
technology makes the most sense long
reads on the other hand can resolve
regions of the genome that are
inaccessible to short reads due to
repeat sequences
NGS allows researchers to explore
genetic variations like never before
down to a single nucleotide resolutions
whether you need to identify specific
variants from a focused set of regions
or look more broadly for potential
causative variations whole exam
sequencing or whole genome sequencing
both offer effective Solutions
whole exam sequencing is a targeted view
of the protein coding regions of the
genome it offers reliable and sensitive
detection of coding variants its fast
and cost effective whole genome
sequencing or the other hand provides a
comprehensive view of the genome as far
as the coding non-coding and
mitochondrial DNA is reliable and
sensitive as well but includes the
detection of all the variant types it's
low cost and a fast method of of Library
preparation as well
we will learn about the sequencing
process transcriptom sequencing is a
major advance in the study of gene
expression because it allows a snapshot
of the whole transcriptom rather than a
predetermined subset of genes
whole transcript term sequencing
provides a comprehensive view of a
cellular transcription profile at a
given biological moment and greatly
enhances the power of RNA Discovery
methods and to study this data we will
learn about processing the pipelines in
our next sessions that turn raw reads
into structured data that is ready for
analysis
we'll also discuss about metagenomic and
viral sequencing techniques and
processes in the next sessions we learn
how a genome is assembled and referred
for annual uh and report for analyzing
data from different resources to
biological insights for designing a
better therapeutic approach
when dealing with infectious diseases
different types of data may be collected
and analyzed to better understand the
disease and its transmission patterns
such as epidemiological data which
includes information about the incidence
prevalence and distribution of the
disease in a particular population which
includes age gender and geographic
location or it could be clinical data
this includes information about the
signs and symptoms of the disease as
well as many medical tests or treatments
that are used to diagnose or manage the
disease laboratory data which includes
information about any laboratory tests
or analysis that are performed on
samples from patients such as blood or
tissue samples to detect the presence of
the pathogen causing the disease
or it could be environmental data which
includes information about the physical
environment in which the disease is
occurring including factors such as
temperature humidity and pollution
levels
genetic data also includes information
about the genetic makeup of the pathogen
causing the disease as well as the
genetic makeup of the host population
which can be helpful to identify any
genetic risk factor that may be
associated with the disease
apart from this you also have social and
Behavioral or economic data and by
analyzing this different these different
types of data researchers and public
health officials can gain a better
understanding of how the disease is
spreading what factors may be
contributing to its spread and how best
to control and prevent the transmission
in the next sessions we will deal with
each one of them
let's now discuss about different angios
types advances and the applications of
Illumina sequencing technique nanopore
and Pat biosequencing technique
some of you might be from an
undergraduation or graduation level and
a different background uh as of
bioinformatics so we quickly wanted to
go through these different types of
sequencing techniques and methods to
give you a good background
so let's start with the first sequencing
technique alumina that is widely used
DNA sequence in technology that allows
for high throughput and low cost
sequencing of data it uses a process
that is called sequencing by synthesis
where nucleotides are added to a growing
strand of DNA and the incorporation is
detected by by fluorescent dyes the
resulting data is then used to generate
a sequence of DNA based pairs Illumina
sequencing is commonly used in many
areas of biology including genomic
research and personalized medicine
nanopore sequencing is a technology for
DNA sequencing that works by passing a
single strand of DNA through a protein
pore which even with each nucleotide
causing a change in the ionic current as
it passes through
and these changes are detected and used
to generate a sequence of the DNA
molecule
whereas the biosequencing is a single is
a single molecule real time DNA
sequencing technology that uses
polymerase enzymes to synthesize long
strands of DNA which are then imaged as
they pass through a zero mode wave guide
the sequencing process generates long
reads with average read lengths
typically ranging from 5 to 15 kilo
paces
so what are the different types of
genomic sequencing techniques let's
understand the basics of targeted whole
genome and whole exam sequencing
the targeted sequencing is a method of
DNA sequencing that focuses on specific
regions of interest in a general
it is more efficient and cost effective
alternative to whole genome sequencing
and can provide higher coverage and
accuracy for specific genes or genomic
regions whole genome sequencing is the
process of determining the complete DNA
sequence of an organism's Journal it
provides a comprehensive and high
resolution view of the entire genome
including both the coding and the
non-coding regions whereas whole exome
sequencing is a type of DNA sequencing
that focuses on the EXO which is the
portion of the genome that contains
exons exons are the parts of the gene
that contains the instructions for
making a protein
now let's discuss about different
Technologies for DNA and RNA sequencing
again just going through it to briefly
have an overview for beginners
which includes micro error sequencing
High throughput sequencing and qpcr
micro error sequencing which is also
known as DNA microarray or DNA chip
technology is a method of analyzing
variations in DNA sequences
High throughput sequencing also known as
Next Generation sequencing is a powerful
technology for large-scale DNA
sequencing it enables the rapid and
simultaneous sequencing of millions or
billions of short DNA fragments
providing a high resolution view of the
genome this technology has evolutionized
the field of genomics and has a wide
range of applications including genome
sequencing transcriptome analysis
epigenetic studies and metagenomics
the quantitative PCR technique the last
one is a widely molecular is widely used
molecular biology technique for
measuring the amount of DNA in a sample
the qpcr is a real-time quantitative
method that enables the measurement of
specific DNA sequences in a sample by
monitoring the amplification of DNA in
real time as the reaction progresses
these different steps of genomic data
analysis typically involves several file
formats including uh let's start with
the first one the raw data which
typically isn't the first few format for
sequencing data The Next Step that is
quality control and pre-processing where
we have trimmed and filtered reads that
are stored in first view format quality
control reports are stored in PDF or
HTML format
the next step for alignment the reads
are aligned to reference genome in ban
that is binary alignment map format
which is a binary version of the Sam
format Sam sequence alignment map
the next step for variant calling where
the variants are stored in VCF parents
calling file format which contains
information about the location type and
quality of genetic variations and then
comes The annotation where variants are
annotated with functional information
stored in GFF or gdf format GFF stands
for General feature format gtf stands
for Gene transfer format now different
analysis of the pipelines may require
additional file formats such as bed that
is browser extensible data for Interval
analysis or wig wiggle format for
continuous data like chip seed signal
tracks it's worth noting that many
bioinformatics tools and pipelines will
automatically convert between these
formats as needed for different steps of
analysis
in the next sessions where we will have
a practical Hands-On with different
types of data we'll run these pipelines
with different types of data files and
have a look for these files include and
how to interpret the results that we get
from the different files like away and
calling file or how do we annotate them
the sequencing data is stored in several
different file formats that I just
mentioned let's quickly have a look at
each one of these file formats
so let's begin with past queue fastq
provides us with the reads from the
sequencer it is a text based file format
that shows nucleotide sequences of reads
and quality scores for each letter
faster is a text-based format for
representing DNA and protein sequences
typically this is the reference file for
the genome then we have the gtf5 which
contains the known annotation for
example the gtf will store the start and
the end of a genomic element Exon
isoform and Gene
genomes are assembled from Next
Generation sequencing techniques which
is typically done using a process called
shotgun sequencing the process includes
shattering The Source material RNA or
DNA and then sequencing short reads of
30 to 300 base per long these sequences
are assembled into a full genome by
looking at the consensus sequence in
other words if the sequence of the reads
all shows the exact same letters they
are considered the consensus if there is
a disagreement the majority wins as a
result from a single isolate we can get
the full sequence of a viral genome that
is most abundant and this process is
fairly accurate however it reduces the
diversity of potential present
variations of the virus in each sample
to a single sequence
the major sample sequenced the higher is
our confidence that that a strain has
consistent characteristics
and after these sequences are found we
can start looking at the genome
characteristics such as genes or special
coding sequences that can be associated
with a function
let's first speak about the sequence
itself
like faster
is commonly used file format for
representing nucleotide or protein
sequence data it is a plain text format
that includes a header line beginning
with a greater than character followed
by one or more lines of sequence data
first cube is another commonly used file
format in bioinformatics particularly
responsible or particularly represents
Next Generation sequencing data it
includes both the neurotype sequence
data and quality scores for each base
then we have the BAM and the Sam files
that are file formats used in
bioinformatics for storing and
exchanging aligned sequence data
particularly for data from Next
Generation sequencing experiments sum is
a text based format that stores aligned
reads in a tabby Limited Format each
line of a samp file represents an
individual read and contains information
such as the read ID its alignment
position its mapping quality and the
actual sequence and quality Source uh
scores the Sam files are human readable
and can be edited using a text editor
however they can be quite large
particularly for NGS data which can
result in slow processing and high
storage requirements whereas the band
finds they are compressed binary version
of the sum format
it stores the same information as the
sample but in a bind by but in a binary
format that is much more Compact and can
be processed much more quickly by
bioinformatics software the BAM files
are generated by compressing the samp
files using the sample software and they
are preferred format for storing the NGS
data due to the efficient storage and
processing
both bam and the Sam files they include
information about the aligned rates
including the mapping position strand
quality score and any potential
mismatches or index compared to a
reference sequence they are used for a
wide range of Downstream analysis
applications which includes variant
calling gene expression quantification
and functional annotation
in this program we learn to visualize
the sequence as the mapped or as they
are mapped on the reference genome and
look at the variance of Interest while
annotating them using databases like
Lenoir dbsnp and Cosmic
as a result
we we will see how important level
variation can be studied from the codon
level to view to study the variant types
for single and multi-nucleotide
variation
we'll also focus on processing and
Analysis methods that are used to
analyze and integrate genomic and
transcriptomic data
we learn about the analysis methods and
tools for genomic and transcriptomic
data analysis of host pathogen
interaction the methods to study
relationship between our relationship
based on local and Global multiple
sequence alignment
phylogenetic analysis reconstruction of
a tree and evolutionary studies that are
used for genome ancestry and population
Fitness
we'll also discuss about chemical and
structural implications of sequence
variation mapped on the pdb models and
discuss the Immunology of forced
pathogen interaction and pathway
analysis of treatment response
where we will consider common
considerations for accurate
discrimination between statistically
significant and insignificant variance
at the read level as well as advanced
methods to decongulate such as coverage
variation in large data sets
we will also discuss methods for
differential variant calling that can
help us compare multiple samples for
associations with phenotype ultimately
we will find the way such studies can
help explain captured data from the
point of view of a mechanistic model of
replication immune response and disease
pathogenesis that all contribute to the
variability between and within each
sample based on but and single cell data
we'll also construct a phylogenetic
trees tracing how The observed species
we capture can represent a common source
origin and even evolutionary time that
separates multiple samples in a study
such phylogenetic Studies have yielded
important information on how a pandemic
or even disease of a single individual
cages with time and gives rise to novel
pathogens we will use the example of
outbreaks like the Ebola virus epidemic
of
2014-2016 and the ongoing covid-19
pandemic
relying on easy to use tools for
multiple sequence alignment and
annotation databases that show the
organization of elements in the viral
genomes we will be able to replicate the
key findings referenced in top
peer-reviewed journals on the emergence
and evolution of sarskov 2.
we will learn about different public
repositories that you can leverage
extract the data from and for further
analysis
we will look at the variability of
retired sequences between all the
coronaviruses to find specific genes or
even the regions that are less conserved
and discuss their functional
significance
we'll then go beyond sequence analysis
where 3D structures and transcriptomic
data can help us understand the
implications of genomic variants that we
identify
as we see here similarity scores are
especially low in the spike glycoprotein
which is responsible for the attachment
of the viruses to the host cell
we also further do an evolutionary
analysis of genome sequences from the
2013-16 epidemic that have provided a
clear picture of the origin and spread
of Ebola virus one of the most important
early questions was whether the epidemic
was the result of a single cross species
transmission event into humans or
whether there were repeated genotic
events from a widespread animal above
Reservoir
due to the high genetic similarity of
virus genome sample from the beginning
of the epidemic a single spillover
infection seems to be most likely the
case
phylogenetic analysis also makes it
clear that once the outbreak was
established later in ages of above
macona have descended from those
circulating earlier in the epidemic and
this is in contrast to some of the
earlier eud outbreaks in which the
epidemiological and sequence-based
investigations have provided evidence
for multiple spillover infections
here we review the methods for the
analysis of HDs reads including
approaches to local diversity estimation
and Global haplotype reconstruction
challenges posed by aligning reads as
well as the impact of reference biases
on diversity estimates that are also
discussed in addition we address some of
the experimental approaches designed to
improve the biological signal to noise
ratio and in future the computational
methods for the analysis of
heterogeneous virus populations are
likely to continue being complemented by
technological developments taking this
into regards will also do a Hands-On
with these different softwares where we
can visualize these holes and understand
the host pathogen interaction
the heterogeneous mixture of viral
strains appear to comfort numerous
advantage to the virus population which
includes the ability to escape from the
host's immune response and the
development of resistance to vaccines
and antiviral drugs
furthermore the existence of different
wild streams have significant
implications for viral pathogenesis
virulence persistence and disease
progression and likely contributes to
tissue tropism the robust adaptability
that is featured by RNA viruses which is
related to the genetic heterogeneity is
thus of clinical relevance that we would
discuss in fact many of the infectious
diseases which have jeopardized and
still are a threat to Public Health are
caused by RNA viruses including HIV hcv
and influenza virus Ebola virus and also
zika virus
we explore some case studies as well as
we proceed in the program such as
malaria sarskov 2 Ebola ebd68 and
tuberculosis
tuberculosis is a contagious infection
that usually attacks the lungs it can
also spread to other parts of the body
like the brain and the spine and a type
of bacteria called mycobacterium
tuberculosis causes it in the 20th
century TV was a leading cause of death
in the United States and today most
cases are cured with antibiotics
also we'll go through some Publications
and case studies uh throughout the
training program and these methods will
include Hands-On exercises on the T
bioinfo platform which provides a simple
intuitive user interface for processing
analysis and machine learning methods
for multi-omics data and towards the end
you can also work on your project
fundamental guidance by applying the
gain skill set from the training program
so that is all that I wanted to discuss
today I just wanted to get you all
started with uh discussing about uh some
of the NGS techniques and also what
we'll go through uh in the next sessions
of the program
I would now like to take you through the
omics logic learn portal and the program
page
to discuss about what are we going to
cover in the next sessions we didn't
want to overwhelm you a lot so to get
started I think uh we have a good
beginning if you have any questions you
can please put in the chat box I will
now share my screen
to have my
uh can you confirm if you can see the
Onyx logic non portal on the screen
here we can see the coating
thank you SRI body
all right so now uh we are here on on
the amishologic learn portal
I would refer to the program page and I
will also tell you what which all
coursework or resources are associated
with this program
so once you click on the programs tab if
you know the track of the program page
you can go to the porters click on the
programs Tab and here you have this
program which is infectious diseases for
bioinformatics research you need to
click on this and when you click on the
program you will get the program page
this is the second
all right now once you are here on the
program page the registered participants
can see on uh find the program page
patch on their profile I don't have the
batch right now on my profile but those
who have been told for the program they
should see the badge of infectious
diseases on their profile if it's not
there please tell us in the chat box so
that we can add one it's important to
have this path so that you you can
access the recordings after the live
session and also go through the
associated resources that are mentioned
here
okay
and now once you register for the
program for the registration how do you
register for the program I'll pass on
the stage to sugar for the first session
we have invited all the interested
participants who wanted to join the
infectious diseases program so that you
get an idea of how the program would be
conducted online by Zoom classes and
what the structure of the program would
be like
now once you're on the program page and
you scroll down you can find the
schedule that uh includes all the
details of the sessions that would be
held on which all dates the sessions
would be held I mean it would be usually
around the same time as uh today's 8 30
PM IST or 9 am CST and here you have the
topics for each of these sessions now
with the topics you can see some
Associated resources these are actually
courses or lessons of the courses on the
omics logic learn portal they all are
hyperlinked if you click on it you'll
get redirected to a specific lesson of
the course that you need to go through
all right and here you have a mix of
context images videos to supplement your
knowledge and towards the end you have a
quiz that you have to answer I'll also
take you to the source of these courses
so that you have the access and know
where the resources are present and you
can go through it uh
otherwise separating to the next session
would be held on Feb 21st where we'll
discuss about multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny the structure of
the program is such that we will first
of all discuss the concepts first and
then we'll take you on the table info
server on the t-buy info server and then
we'll practice the pipelines we lower
Hands-On and we also have some R lessons
for uh multiple sequence alignment
phylogenetic analysis
Etc will showcase the resources to you
as well the r lessons are though not
included in the program but if you are
interested to learn the Computing
language are for planning out all these
different types of analysis with
infectious diseases you uh you can go
through those lessons
all right so you have the topics
mentioned here you have to program I
just put the program page Link in the
chat for you
yes so you can go through each one of
these topics uh I'm not actually reading
all the topics right now we're here just
telling you about the sessions the next
session would be about multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny and then we'll
have a hand one session where we pick up
the case study of covert and we'll also
discuss about ebola briefly we'll have
session where we'll just discuss about
the pipelines that you all process and
then look at your results and clarify
your questions and then we'll discuss
about how uh infection leads to
pandemics and uh how the transmission
happens we'll discuss about symptom
severity disease progression the
outcomes and we'll also discuss about
different case studies rate of mutation
mutation annotation and saying that is
significant for analysis and host
pathogen interaction
so we'll be going through all of these
different topics throughout the program
and uh just showing you the T bioinfo
platform to answer some of the questions
and Curiosities by the participants here
so we have two platforms one is the
omnisogic learn portal that is the
training platform you will learn from
these different courses on the omnisogic
learn portal specifically for this
program we'll be taking you through the
genomics uh course and the metagenomics
course as well
and uh these are the courses that you
will go to build up some Concepts and
also to learn how different analysis
could be carried out using the T bioinfo
platform and also through Computing
languages like R and then we'll also go
through some case studies to understand
how some research questions could be
answered with the skill set that you
gain throughout this program now when I
say these research studies you can click
on the project star and then infectious
diseases we have case studies on coval
Ebola evening 68s products
and then a surveillance of SARS spoke to
as well we'll go to go through some of
these case studies and try to understand
the emergence of these different uh
infectious diseases uh we'll try to
compare the different strains and also
we'll try to understand the pathogenesis
and uh some transcriptional signatures
and biomarkers that we could identify
for the treatment
now coming back to the T bioinfo
platform
uh I wanted to mention those who have
enrolled for the program
you might have received an email by SRI
gauri
uh for the Onyx logic learn poetry your
credentials would remain the same that
you would create for yourself but as a
part of this program you get an
educational premium license on the T
bioinfo server and to activate the same
we change your passwords for the server
so you will get the credentials for the
server your login ID will remain the
same as your email ID with which you
signed up and uh your password would
change
and using the set of credentials that we
send you via your email you should be
able to get an access to these Pipelines
now these are the two sections that
we'll go through
the genomics one and phylogenetic
analysis one and if you click on these
drop down buttons you have some demo
pipelines that you can run through and
see what types of results you get and
how do you interpret them otherwise in
the program we will explore data from
different data reposit please we'll
extract them we'll prepare the data and
then we'll run these pipelines and when
we run these pipelines we'll use some
different tools or algorithms for data
pre-processing mapping visualization
meaning calling and annotation what
these algorithms are what do they do how
do they process the data what output you
get how do you interpret the output
there are a lot of things in this
workflow to answer so we'll look at each
one of these different steps one by one
throughout these sessions and also
um to supplement your knowledge we have
the content in the course first world
that you have to go through as a part of
each and every session and also you have
to practice these pipelines and then
interpret the results
and then here is the phylogenetic
analysis pipeline as today was the first
session I just wanted to briefly give
you an overview of what is inside the
program what we learn what pipelines
will be uh run
and also what does the access time so
that there are no more confusions
and also after the live sessions once
the recording is processed we'll upload
it on the program page so you can revise
the concepts go through the recording
once again uh on the program page I'll
show you some other program where we
have already uploaded the recording so
that you can see how the recording comes
up
if there are any questions you can put
in put them in the chat so that we can
address
that was it that I wanted to mention
uh if you have not registered yourself
for the program yet you won't have the
patch once you register
then you'll have the batch
I'm not sure if you have received your
registration our team will check and
then we'll get back to you on this
uh I would I'm just opening up a program
page that is ongoing to show you how the
recordings are uploaded so this is on
the program page you have the recording
like this and you then you can uh go
through it
now that was it I would stop sharing and
would pass on the stage to Subhan to
help those uh who are interested to
enroll for the program but are not have
not registered now
all right
over to you
thank you so much sonalika that was a
very wonderful and informative like
overview session we can say
so hello everyone I'll just share my
screen I'm shubham I'll be like briefing
you about the enrollment and the
registration part for all those who are
like interested uh to and like go with
this program
um
we have 11 sessions
foreign
all right so uh is my screen visible
yes yes
okay so uh like as you all can see and
like uh mentioned by sonalika uh that
this is a program page for the
Infectious Disease by informatics
research on applied genomics and it will
like the like course has already been
commenced from today like Feb 17 to 30th
April so furthermore like if you scroll
down you will see that there is a
program overview section so what all
topics you will be getting to learn and
what all Concepts you will be going
while this program and like uh some of
the Hands-On sessions will also be
covering so all these parts we have
covered in this program overview section
like you will be getting an opportunity
to practice the like hands-on experience
with the data sets available on the
public domain to know about the like
phylogenetic interactions between hosts
and the viruses
so coming down more you can see that
there is an interactive calendar we can
say with some of the dates which are
highlighted like today 17 is highlighted
on that particular day like on the the
the the dates which are highlighted on
these particular dates we will be having
a live sessions so let's say like today
we had a first session and we have
learned about the Next Generation
sequencing viral genomes in host
transcriptom and what all different
topics we have covered you can see here
like types of infectious diseases then
uh recent Publications then types of NGS
data you all can go through apart from
that you can see that there are some of
the associated online resources which
you can go through to know more about
the topics and similarly our next
session will be there on Feb 21st and we
will be covering the multiple sequence
alignment and phylogeny part so coming
down more as you score down you will see
that we have three different tenures one
is for 45 days 60 days and 90 days so
the like common resources or the common
outcomes for all these three resources
is you will be getting the online
tutorials you will be getting a chance
to work on the project examples
available on the learn portal also you
will be getting a Hands-On coding
sessions and by chance let's say uh if
you miss some of the live sessions so no
need to worry about that we will share
the session recordings as well apart
from that you will be getting online
mentor and technical support and once uh
your program is over then we will
provide you with this certificate of
completion and along with that you will
be getting the access of T by info
server so for the 60 days what extra you
will be getting is you will be getting a
one-on-one mentorship session and uh
while going through the courses let's
say you come up with your own research
idea to work on so you can is like even
propose your research question and you
can like share it with the mentor and
along with that you will be getting an
opportunity to like present your
research proposal as a in the form of a
poster in various International
symposiums level and in the 90 days you
will be get the like a license and
one-on-one mentorship will be there and
you will get an ample amount of time to
work on a research question and like you
can like properly perform your research
work and you will be getting a chance to
get it published in the peer review
journal
so these all are the resources and the
art forms for all these three different
terminals
coming to the pricing part as you all
can see on the screen that for 45 days
we have INR 7500 for Indian and Asian
customers we can say and for 60 days we
have like nine triple nine and for 90
days it is 14 triple nine let's say uh
like some of our participants are from
African region so here you all can see
that there is a drop down so just click
on that and you can select this uh
thing like naira ngn so you can see that
the pricing have changed to naira like
for 45 days it is 49 triple nine for 60
days it is 99 triple nine and for 90
days it is 149 triple nine and let's say
some of uh the participants are from us
or some other countries so they can also
see their pricing similar to this uh
like uh in USD also like dollar 150 then
dollar three hundred and dollar for 450.
so how to enroll for this particular
program so let's say I'm interested in
the 45 in 90 days tenor so what you have
to do is just simply click on the binom
button and you will be directed to a
checkout page like this is your checkout
page yeah so you will be like reviewing
your order like this program
you just simply have to fill up your
user details name I email ID then your
education and after that don't forget to
click on this check box and after that
to select any of the payment method like
stripe or PayPal or if you are facing
any issue you can like mail us we have
Alternatives also like bank transfer and
for Indian customers we have that you
pay option is also there we have
alternative methods for the payment part
so this was all about the registration
and enrollment part if you have any
questions please feel free and I'll
address those things
thank you
thank you so much so uh does the
participants have any queries regarding
the registration or
regarding the environment please let us
know and we'll be happy to answer
we'll pause for a couple of seconds for
the participants to share their query
if you wish to receive for those
participants who have not enrolled yet
but want to get more details about the
program as well as the scholarship
details kindly share your email ID in
the chat box so that we can mail you
regarding
details
thank you so much
what about the best of you if you have
any query please share your
queries in the chat I will be happy to
answer
thank you so much I can see that the
participants are sharing their email ID
we will be taking a note of all of that
yes we will send you the scholarship
details on your email ID that we have
shared
we have a query from Sunil he is asking
are there any fully funded scholarship
for the program
uh so I like uh unfortunately we do not
have any such uh like fully funded
scholarship but yes like uh up to like
50 percent scholarship is there so uh
like I will uh like you can mail us uh
or you can share our email ID we will
share you with the like details
scholarship details and the scholarship
form so that you know you can fill up
that form and we can provide you this
scholarship
or else you can contact us at
[Music]
okay
so I have shared the like uh contact you
can mail us at marketing at omics
logic.com or you can message us on
WhatsApp uh the number I have provided
active on WhatsApp so we will provide
you with these scholarship details and
those all who have like shared their
email ID we will also be like providing
with the session recordings and the
scholarship part
thank you
thank you so much
do we have any product queries if so
please share
and if anyone is left to share their
email ID please do so otherwise we'll be
ending today's session
all right then if everyone has share
their email ID we'll be ending today's
session so thank you so much everyone
for joining and the program participants
if you have any queries please feel free
to reach out to us through the WhatsApp
group or our email IDs and for those of
you who have not enrolled we look
forward to seeing your registration and
in the upcoming session thank you so
much everyone for joining and have a
great
thank you bye